les occidentaux eux accélèrent leurs
livraisons d'armes aux ukrainiens on
verra ce que dira joe biden dans un
instant mais les britanniques et les
allemands presse le pas et le kremlin à
linverse estime que ces livraisons
d'armes menace la sécurité européenne
gauthier rybinski bonjour on est dans
l'escaladé verbale en ce moment oui elle
n'est pas nouvelle mais vous savez cette
escalade de la part du kremlin elle
fonctionne à propos des armes et elle
fonctionne à propos de tout autre chose
aussi quand le secrétaire général de
l'onu a été reçu par rohff et bien que
s'est il passé
les les jours nous qui sont en service
commandé du kremlin on dit de toute
manière cette visite ne sert à rien
puisque la demande de couloirs
humanitaires est un as tu une atteinte
au droit de la rue si vous voyez où on
en est c'est à dire penser que des
couloirs qui permettront aux civils de
s'enfuir sont des atteintes aux halles à
la sécurité des de la russie c'est
absolument impensable alors pour abonder
dans votre sens cette réflexion sur la
teneur agressive des propos du kremlin
il y à un moyen d'y répondre lors vous
avez dit effectivement la grande
bretagne et l'allemagne pressent le pas
l'allemagne c'est d'autant plus étonnant
que jusqu'il ya peu de temps elle était
assez réfractaire à ce genre de démarche
mais si vous voulez on est dans une
bataille qui est une bataille rhétorique
aussi et bataille rhétorique c'est quand
par exemple lavrov ou poutine disent qu'
il ya une peu une éventualité un risque
troisième guerre mondiale comment
répondre à cela et bien pendant 20 ans
ou un peu moins l'occident a répondu à
cela par la conciliation avec poutine ça
n'a pas marché la preuve la géorgie
l'ukraine le dos de base est aujourd'hui
à nouveau l'ukraine donc ça veut dire
qu'il faut répondre d'une manière ou
d'une autre avec cette fermeté vous
allez me dire et je sais vous allez me
dire que je suis dur trop dur vous
l'avez dit hors antenne mais si il
s'agit d'amoindrir les effets
dévastateurs de cette guerre c'est
peut-être justement en musclant le
discours et la rhétorique vis-à-vis de
poutine alors que lui si vous voulez et
profondément comment dire ça excite et
par là
la lâcheté la mollesse du discours
occidental c'est quelque chose qu'il qui
lui procure une forme de plaisir de
toute manière et c'est là dessus que je
terminerais quelle que soit la manière
dont on considère poutine on peut penser
qu'il n'aura jamais il sera jamais en
manque de prétexte pour mener telle ou
telle action militaire dans ce cas là
donc pourquoi ne pas tester essayer de
stopper au moins symboliquement une
action par un discours beaucoup plus
fermé beaucoup plus musclée par exemple
ses livraisons d'armes il faut les
défendre coûte que coûte et dire si les
soldats russie attaque il y aura des
réponses foudroyante on reste dans le
même vague que poutine mais il y à un
cran dans la terminologie qui est passé